hey what's up it's chris
okay no laughing no laughing hey welcome
back it's chris and today we're gonna
find a date for vanessa vanessa you're
gonna try three different chinese dishes
cooked by three different guys and then
you decide who you are gonna go on a
date with just based on those dishes
sound good yeah sounds good i was born
in guangdong the south part of china i
came in when i was like eight months old
i do have a lot of experience because my
grandma cooks um traditional like
chinese food like every day like
cantonese style i feel like how you
gonna tell if the guy is funny by his
cooking i guess if it's like there's
like a little twist to the traditional
chinese meal then maybe like says
something about his personality yo what
up i'm zakoon hey what's up i'm leo hey
guys i'm tom i'm a very
efficient person i'm like really messy
honestly like hopefully it tastes good
i'm pretty confident in my dish but i
expect my competitors to be very good at
what they're doing
this is my hong kong style seafood fried
rice a little different that i did was i
wanted to make it a little bit healthier
so a lot of veggies and i use brown rice
instead also to kind of elevate that
fried rice dish i use seafood so you got
shrimp calamari
squid scallops as well this kind of dish
you got to make sure there's eggs you
got to make sure there's a lot of good
seasoning presentation is everything i'm
a fashion travel influencer so how you
present yourself to the world right so i
kind of want to reflect that in my dish
i think it's got everything so let's see
is this something you make on a regular
i don't make chinese dishes that much i
usually do a lot of like healthy
balanced meals like proteins and veggies
you know i i try to keep fit so i don't
eat that much carb normally you know
it's a little bit special to make
something like this it smells good but
the sky definitely doesn't cook like
chinese food on the regular i feel like
he's very americanized
he did not my grandma don't use these
ingredients it feels like most of the
ingredients are like out of a bag that's
so much work so much dude yeah i'm not
gonna buy all fresh things first thing
yeah he made it with seafood that's a
little different is it
three juices
it's kind of bland bro oh not one for
spicy but like you know like you need a
little bit the guy said he's just really
efficient about how he cooks things oh
that makes sense like it feels like he
just like opened like his freezer he's
like what do i got and then you just
threw everything in a pan you know
that's a good quality to have like being
fast better than being slow when you're
hungry ten minutes i got you so how
attractive do you think this guy is
um what kind of question is that
what kind of question is that about my
presentation there's like a lot of
vegetables in here so i feel like the
sky maybe goes to the gym yeah gosh here
we go
he wanted you to notice his presentation
he says it means a lot to him just
presenting yourself to the world it's
fried rice like just build it on this
plate and cut some scallions i feel like
that's very low effort
she's gonna be brutal bro i feel like
this guy is pretty sloppy you know like
he might not be the one you know
all right she said it might not be she
tried to let you down easy anything else
you want to say about this guy i've said
enough
i'm sorry guy won
well i made something very simple i made
mapo tofu but i put a little bit of a
twist on it's like sichuan style so it's
a little spicy it's healthy it's yummy
this guy look at this there's a master
chef over here you got all these
ingredients he packed the whole grocery
store with him let's look at that i'm in
food service guys come on this guy so i
have some ground up sichuan peppers
there's a powder so sichuan pepper
powder i have some scallions that i cut
up extra chinese chilies i have a side
in case it's too spicy this cuts the
heat this is a pickled cucumbers and
over here i have my rice and my tofu i
make this for my mom and she loves it
too i kind of want to try something
oh i like that
yes
i think i like this guy already
that's it guys
this actually looks really nice yeah i
really like the presentation of this one
you know yo this is everything like the
last guy was like lacking
guys stuff it's not usually the dish i
go for but since everything looks so
nice like i'm gonna go for it i hope
it's good oh and i like this rice you
know there's different types of rice i
like this kind oh you picked out the
rice dude this guy this is too good
this guy like just totally gets it like
oh it's like not too spicy it was really
good
yes oh she's already going for the
second bite yeah she's like she wasn't
even thinking
what other specific things about his
personality can you figure out and also
is he attractive do you think he's hot
do you think he's a guy you want to date
i feel like he's pretty attractive based
on this dish i would say this guy i feel
like he puts effort yeah like i feel
like this guy can take care of me you
know and i let him
i feel bad for the first guy
okay oh my god listen i want to try that
too oh i definitely would like to meet
this guy yeah everything's good i have
no bad comments
like the last one
i mean i don't even blame her at this
point
wait that's actually so good right
my dish i made a quentin soup i actually
learned how to make it last night so
yeah this is a miso soup mix there's one
that came kind of loose so i'm just
gonna hide that a little bit so you
cannot see my flaws it's cracked white
pepper powder that's all i need i don't
need all these like 10 different
garnishes all you need is one it's a
cold day today like you know i thought i
took that into account when i was
picking a dish and i was like you know
what i want when it's a cold day i want
something like you know warm like you
know it's kind of stewie or soupy you
know it's kind of rich and like umami
flavor so you know like i want like a
big hearty dish so you know that's why i
kind of picked pumpkin soup and all that
so hopefully it says something good
about me i think a for effort for sure
that's a lot that's hard to make yeah
damn yeah guy number three i like
wontons
yeah he made those by hand wow this is a
family man he can take care of my kids
you know like he can make them wontons
damn she reads you like a book that
means you already have kids and have a
family
i mean like she has potential wow
maybe the wonton will taste better
i'm not sure if we can call this soup
no
it's actually instant broth that he just
packaged
that makes sense seems like this man
cuts corners you know oh god yeah she's
literally kicking you while you're down
he's probably like oh hope she doesn't
notice
i don't like that
my deepest condolences the wontons it's
kind of dry never thought that i would
say that about a long time damn i just
want her to say
so how attractive is he would you date
him
i feel like this guy definitely has a
chance you know because like i like
wontons and like he made them himself
the soup was really disappointing
so maybe like you know you know what
they say like if you lack in where in
one area like you can make up in another
that's
a chance is all we need thank you
overall how are these three guys i
really like wontons i feel like in this
case everything's just kind of plain oh
no it may be kind of boring you know
because this is like pretty like a basic
chinese dish he just doesn't try the
best maybe in just in this area this guy
i feel like he did kind of try
stifling's not my favorite vegetables
are not my favorite he's just too
different from you he's just too
different yeah he would be like you want
to go to like the museum and i'd be like
no
but this guy everything is just perfect
and the date would be exciting and i
wouldn't be like waiting for the date to
be over you know i'd be like
that's it all right we're going to go to
one of your places we're going to eat
some water fried rice
you ready to meet him yeah
all right vanessa come on in hi
you selected tom as your date hi tom
nice to meet you nice to meet you i'm
leo i'm zakoon hi do you have anything
to say to them
i think i've said all i needed to say
if i were you i would have picked that
one too
i am going to send you guys off on a
little mini date and you'll be able to
talk for a bit and we'll check back in
and see what you guys want to do after
that does that sound good sure great
let's do it let's go
thank you everyone for coming today's
ceremony you may now kiss the bride i'm
missing something
did you just use your right hand
i did was she accurate in her
psychoanalysis of you do you think she
understood your truest vibe i think she
was close she actually got a lot of us
where are you taking her on your next
date oh we're going to go to leo's house
and then we're going to eat monsants
this is cold
stop eating it i want you guys to make a
cute little couple pose to like make a
heart like this and then you gotta say
thank you for watching like comment
subscribe sounds good perfect great is
that cringy all right tell me if the
heart is like straight you know
oh i'm in so much pain right now
we're gonna cut our video thank you for
watching